Speaker 1: So, David, you do admit that UFOs
exist? Well, what does UFO mean? It means
unidentified flying object. It's different than
intelligent alien species from another country.
And yet another one of these UFOs has been
shot down by the United States. Increasingly,
the question is, what exactly are these? The
latest claim is they are in the balloon category,
generally similar to that first surveillance
balloon believed to be from China that was
shot down off the coast of South Carolina, but
not exactly the same. And it is still early days
and we are trying to gather information. So
let's go to what we know and what took place.
CNN reporting on Saturday. U.S. jet shoots down
Unidentified Object over northern Canada, Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau said Saturday
an unidentified object had been shot down by
a U.S. fighter jet over Canadian airspace. On his
orders, I ordered the takedown of an unidentified
object that violated Canadian airspace, nor had
command shot down the object over the Yukon.
Canadian and U.S. aircraft were scrambled and
a U.S. F-22 successfully fired at the object.
The object is being described as cylindrical
and smaller than the suspected Chinese balloon
shot down last weekend, according to Canadian
Defense Minister Anita Anand. Later Saturday,
the White House confirmed Trudeau and Joe Biden
authorized the shoot down and the Pentagon said
the object was first spotted over Alaska on Friday
evening. Immediately, questions about was this the
same thing or not? Was it in the category? Is
balloon the right word? Here is what Senator
Chuck Schumer said after being briefed by
National security adviser Jake Sullivan.
Speaker 2: Until they get that comprehensive
analysis, however, we have to look at each balloon
individually where these blew up Saturday night.
They believe they were, yes, but much smaller than
the than the one the first one. Both of those
one over Canada, one over Alaska, where at
40,000 feet immediately, it was determined that
that's a danger to commercial aircraft, which.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so there are sort of a
conspiracy types who are saying, wait a second,
cylindrical object is very different than balloon.
Everybody is lying to us right now. I have no
reason in particular to think anybody is lying to
us, but we do need more information. Of course,
we also have now been presented with the claim
from China that the United States has done the
exact same thing ten times. There is a CNN
article from this morning. China accuses U.S.
of illegally flying balloons across its airspace.
China has accused the U.S. of illegally flying a
high altitude balloons into its airspace more
than ten times since January 2022. Claims that
drew an immediate rebuttal from the White House.
We'll hear that rebuttal in a moment. As bilateral
tensions flare in the fallout from the Chinese
balloon that was shot down by American fighter
jets after traveling across the continental U.S..
Let's look at a clip here of the National Security
Council's John Kirby. Very clearly just denying
that the U.S. does the same thing. Take a listen.
And I believe we have the clip here. Do we
have the clip? Let's see. I love having clips.
Speaker 3: Just in the last hour or two. The
foreign ministry there has accused the United
States since the start of 2022 of flying balloons
ten different times over Chinese airspace. Can
you respond to that accusation?
Speaker 4: Not true. Not doing
it. Just absolutely not true.
Speaker 3: So the US let me just
push you a little further that
so the U.S. is not using these
balloons technologies at all over China?
Speaker 4: That is right. We are not flying
balloons over China. That is absolutely true.
Speaker 1: Now, understand whenever such a
statement is made. In colloquial language,
we would say this is a complete denial.
If you want to play these cynical games,
which are very often accurate, right? I mean,
we call them games, but there's a reason we play
them when there's a couple of critical words,
they're balloons and over China. His statement and
I hate that this is the way stuff is communicated
these days. I am not arguing that such a thing is
or isn't taking place. His statement is. Balloons
aren't being flown over China. Could balloons be
flown off the coast of China? And he wouldn't be
lying? Yeah. Could there be something other than a
balloon flown over China and he wouldn't be lying?
Yeah. So, again, you always want to pay really
close attention to the language that's being
used. I'm not suggesting one thing or the other.
We're just kind of parsing through it. Okay.
Speaker 3: And then lastly, then, just as.
Will there be will that viewpoint be expressed
directly to Beijing beyond here on the friendly
confines of Morning Joe? Well, when did the
next conversation start between Washington and
Beijing over a matter that's clearly inflaming
tensions between the two countries?
Speaker 4: Well, two points here,
Jonathan. First of all, we still have diplomatic
relations with China. We still have an embassy
there. It's not like all communications between
us and the PRC have shut down. Obviously,
there are certain vehicles like military
to military vehicles which are not open
to us right now. And that's unfortunate.
But we do have the ability to communicate
directly with the Chinese leaders. And we have.
Speaker 1: Okay. So relations are still ongoing,
although Kirby says we are absolutely not doing
the same thing. So a couple different things
going on here. Number one, do we do we want
to and should we figure out what exactly these
unidentified flying objects are? Of course
we should. Is it likely that at this point,
official sources know more than they are saying
publicly? Absolutely. Is it likely that the U.S.
is doing equivalent surveillance in China to
what China is doing in the U.S.? Of course,
it might just take different forms. This is
what countries do. It applies to Russia. It
applies to many different countries. And lastly,
at this time, do you have any reason to believe
that these are intelligent aliens? We do not. And
of course, I am mathematically and statistically
open to the possibility of intelligent life out
there in the universe. Do I believe it is this
these these objects that represent that? I have no
reason whatsoever to believe that that's the case.